is he still in frame and focus
everything bouncing around like a
scooter no that's good or like one of
the pogo stick or something or horse are
you the horse that youth right of course
okay good morning believe nation today's
message is know what you want over to
you Iman Abdul Majeed I called the
spoils of war
because in our industry there's where
you make money and the rest of it is
fluff what you do in what's called
editorial in the magazines they pay you
250 dollars a whole day that's not money
there's prestige in it but there that's
not money advertising cosmetic contracts
that's where the money is that's where
they may pay you half a million million
dollars for jobs that's what I want
I wanted that spoils of war yeah yeah
and that's what I fought for it was it
out of and I don't mean this
disrespectful but what's it out of greed
or was it out of wanting to be valued at
value system if you're going to pay that
a month another girl why couldn't you
pay me for the same service I provided
is about that is about that it's not
about greed because if you know because
of the sense if it's usually people who
are about greed they will prostitute
themselves they'll do whatever it takes
to get there and my sense of value was
that I'll sit it out I would have come
my word no way so do you think you know
thinking back to TDS where I want to see
it grow in terms of know what I want I'm
happy the progress that I have made you
have made we've made together but what I
want is to have a TDS in different
provinces I want to have multiple
locations I want TDS to be a chain and
the good work that we do here the escape
that we provide for people the
relaxation the fun having to meet your
future wife or husband hear all that I
want to bring that and I think that TDS
really of all the salsa schools is the
one that really does it well we can
always improve
so I want to bring that kind of sense of
family as a business kill all the
provinces I like it and and then hit the
US for most of the people watching -
there you go
California you know for me I think
there's there's an incredible power to
having an ambitious goal something that
you want to go and accomplish and then
the side to that is believing that you
can actually do it right a lot of us
will set these big ambitious goal but
then we don't actually think we can do
that and so then you don't actually do
the steps that you need to to follow
through you know every time I've had a
major growth in my business it's from
breaking through a limiting belief
thinking that this is this is how big we
can get and then that's what you shoot
towards but then if you break through
and say why can't we be out here like
why can't we be across the country why
can't we be in the u.s. to like why
can't we break out into new markets just
having a conversation changes the way
you do things right if our goal was to
you know I want to I want to grow my
revenue by 25% this year that makes you
act a certain way right you start taking
actions if I wanted to grow
internationally and have ten locations I
start thinking bigger and acting
differently right when I was sitting
down and writing my book it wasn't just
I want to write another book right and
oh my I'm gonna get some of the thoughts
out of my head and put them promote a
book like I want to create one of the
best-selling business books of all time
and that's what I came down and I
started sitting there writing with that
intention and so I think you have to set
goals that our ambitious would then
believe that you can actually accomplish
them and it changes the behavior that
you take on a day to day basis and so I
think most people don't set ambitious
enough goals that they actually think
that they can realize and they live
small and so hopefully this video helps
push you to want to do just a little bit
more so the question of the day today is
what are the first three things that you
can do to achieve what you want first
three things leave in the comments below
we're gonna join the discussion thank
you so much for watching have an amazing
day continue to believe and we'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso thank you so much for
watching
shot of espresso
you said espresso hold on espresso it
was like that one wasn't even close